eric raoult bonsoir vous est ce un
ministre délégué à la ville et à
l'intégration alors fallait-il en passer
par là fallait-il recourir à la force
un artiste ça peut susciter une émotion
un gouvernement c'est fait pour trouver
les solutions j'ai autant de peine que
l'on en soit arrivé là que madame bea je
souhaite simplement qu'après la
clarification après le moment de fermeté
que le gouvernement a été amené à
prendre pour mettre en place pour
appliquer la loi au cas par cas parce
qu'on ne peut pas étudier une situation
administrative dans une sacristie sous
le regard des caméras il faut un débat
contradictoire entre une personne qui
défend sa situation et puis les dossiers
administratifs
il ne faut pas que les sans papiers
soient des 100 dossiers mais je voudrais
ne peut vraiment aller de tout coeur
l'avenir des guerres sales d'un côté les
sans-papiers et de l'autre côté les sons
pitié il faut voir comment tomber en est
arrivé là et voir aussi que comme tous
les autres personnes qui se sont
exprimées et bien j'aurais souhaité
qu'on évite tout ça mais on en est
arrivé là parce que il y a eu d'un côté
une volonté de parvenir à une situation
bloquée et malheureusement avec beaucoup
de récupération vient de le voir avec
les manifestations et de l'autre côté de
la part du gouvernement la volonté de
trouver une solution donc à votre avis
monsieur raoul le gouvernement est allé
jusqu où joue au maximum ce qu'ils
pouvaient faire en terme de négociation
on doit appliquer une loi on peut pas la
négocier si demain il convient de
modifier un texte il faut le faire à
l'assemblée nationale pas dans une
église parce que l'émotion que madame b
a exprimé ce soir sur la télévision je
voudrais aussi qu'elle puisse la
manifester dans un quartier qu'elle
puisse la manifester au mali nous sommes
dans une situation qui est aujourd'hui
en matière d'immigration peut freiner
l'intégration or ces immigrés qui sont
en situation irrégulière pose un réel
problème d'image vis-à-vis de tous ceux
qui sont en situation régulière et qui
veulent vivre une vie comparable à la
nôtre donc je crois qu'il fallait
intervenir mais maintenant que la
fermeté est passé je fais confiance au
ministre de l'intérieur et au premier
ministre qui l'ont montré avec
intelligence et patience pour qu'une
réponse de fraternité et une réponse de
solidarité soient apportées avec
humanité dans ces dossiers justement sur
l'application de la loi le dans son avis
le conseil d'état a donné une très large
marge de manoeuvre au gouvernement
en fonction notamment du droit à une vie
de famille normale dont devraient
bénéficier tout le monde y compris des
étrangers vous croyez que ça te ce
droit-là sera respectée écoutez je crois
que comme l'a dit hier alain juppé les
familles ne seront pas séparer les
personnes en mauvaise santé ne seront
pas expulsés mais il y a aussi des
déboutés du droit d'asile tout
gouvernement les gouvernements
socialistes ont été confrontés au même
problème les autres pays le sont aussi
quand on entre en france ce n'est pas un
hall de gare il faut accepter des règles
le fait d'avoir sa situation revue
réviser comme le premier ministre l'a
annoncé ne veut pas dire une
régularisation massive vous pensez qu'il
faut revoir les lois pasqua puisque leur
application a l'air de poser quand même
des problèmes je crois que les textes de
charles pasqua sont un socle qu'il faut
peut-être adapter dans les années qui
viennent mais qu'il faut d'abord
appliquer l'immigration est un problème
qui ne s'interrompra pas en 1998 c'est
un problème de pauvreté et de richesses
est commis hier le premier ministre l'a
souligné il faudra apporter des réponses
qu'ils soient des réponses aussi de
coopération car tout à l'heure on a
parlé du mali on a parlé également de la
mauritanie ce qu'il faut faire c'est
d'aider les africains restés dans leur
pays les aider au développement pour
éviter qu'ils viennent ici vivent leur
pauvreté leur précarité une toute petite
chose pour terminer on ne lit que
monsieur chirac avait su cette crise de
très près qu'il avait donné des
consignes très fermes de très grande
forme et et c'est quelque chose que vous
confirmez que tel j'ai entendu le
président la république s'exprimait le
14 juillet parlait d'un geste fort et de
l'intégration le geste fort est
intervenue maintenant nous avons encore
beaucoup de travail pour expliquer à
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes que
l'intégration est une chance pour notre
pays mais que nous ne pouvons pas la
faire dans le désordre et il y avait un
des hordes à l'église saint bernard
merci monsieur route